of all the animals that we've examined
in the microcosmos leeches are probably
one of the few that can be used as a
verb
I don't know exactly what it would mean
to tardigrade someone or something but I
do know what it means to leech off
someone to take and take from them like
a worm consuming someone's blood it's
funny though isn't it that we use this
word in such a derogatory way we make an
insult out of an animal we nearly drove
to Extinction in some countries because
we found them so useful
you might even ask then are we the leech
leeching off leeches
[Music]
before we go too deep into sympathizing
with leeches let's be clear leeches are
very creepy for most of us anyway James
our master of microscopes has come
across leeches several times in his pond
samples a few years ago he found two
finger-length black leeches in his
samples and decided to put them in a
container with the lid completely sealed
his Professor warned him that they would
Escape but James figured he'd close the
lid tight enough to ensure that they
would stay in the container so he left
it in the bathroom and he went to bed
the next morning when he went to the
bathroom he saw the one thing you don't
want to see when you have a container
with leeches in your home the lid was on
the floor and the container was empty
they had somehow managed to escape and
now James was in a home with two kittens
and a pair of wayward leeches
thank you
he searched through everything and to
his enormous relief he finally managed
to find the leeches behind his washing
machine covered in dust bunnies but at
least he did learn to not underestimate
them
these leeches we're looking at now are
from a different genus than his runaway
pair but they also posed a challenge
they were able to attach themselves to
the glass of their fish tank with so
much strength that James could not
retrieve them like he normally would and
when they did detach themselves from the
sides of the tank the leeches would
quickly swim down into the sediment and
disappear eventually James was able to
get a hold of them but the struggles
still continued the leeches were simply
not content to rest on the slides they
would Escape they would crawl they would
roll one even jumped down from the
microscope now James was finally able to
Reign the men through a clever
arrangement of slides and cover slips
that let him record them and we are both
grateful for his persistence and very
glad that none of us were in the room
with him and those leeches as we
mentioned earlier leech has the
distinction of referring both to an
animal and an insult inspired by said
animal that might not be unusual when we
look at macroscopic animals but animals
of the microcosmos are of course so
small that they don't often get the
opportunity to permeate our language in
many forms the use of the word leech to
describe a person as a parasite is only
a few centuries old but we have a long
history with the word leech going back
to at least the year 900 CE in Old
English leech could mean one of two
things one is the blood-sucking worm
that we're looking at right now the
other meaning is Doctor the two
definitions actually came into Old
English from two different Origins but
they came to be intertwined in meaning
the way that leeches and doctors have
been intertwined in practice the older
understanding of medicine built upon the
concept of humors that were transported
around the body through blood
bloodletting was seen as a way to
restore balance excess blood it was
thought could lead to disease and so
removing that blood could be a medical
necessity of course you could remove the
blood through surgical means but leeches
were a nice alternative slower not quite
as painful and there are some
afflictions where a patient might prefer
a worm to a doctor stabbing them the
main downside was the need to prevent
leeches from crawling into the patient
through their mouth nose or anus
[Music]
there are actually hundreds of leaf
species but the one used for medical
purposes was named harudo medicinalis in
1758 by Carl Linnaeus in the wild this
worm feeds on mammals fish and
amphibians tracking movements in the
water along with heat and chemical
signals to find their host then it uses
its three jaws and the sharp teeth
lining them to pierce the skin the leech
will usually consume anywhere from a two
to five times their body weight in blood
relying on a cocktail of enzymes and
other molecules in their saliva to keep
the blood flowing and not clotting when
they're done the leech might actually
take months to digest that meal around
the 18th and 19th centuries using
leeches as a medical tool ballooned in
popularity thanks in part to the
influence of the French physician
Francois Joseph Victor Bruce which led
to a massive trade in the worm across
Europe if you read about the history of
leeching you'll find all sorts of
terrifying statistics describing their
use for example in 1832 France was
estimated to have imported more than 50
million leeches
imagine transporting hundreds of
thousands of leeches or maybe you
shouldn't imagine that but of course
trading in leeches also meant catching
them which is easy when you're the exact
host that leeches are looking for leech
Hunters would simply use their feet as
bait extracting the worms from their own
bodies to be able to send them on their
way and look leeches weren't some rare
animal but when people began treating
them in such massive quantities that
changed that was a problem for trade but
also for wild leech populations some
countries approached this problem by
trying to build leech Farms that could
reduce the need for wild leeches others
tried to raise prices or limit exports
sometimes even Banning them
something else was changing as well
scientists started doubting whether
leeches were really that great of a
medical tool to begin with the most
notable opponent was the French
physician Pierre Shaw Alexander Louis
who argued that leeching might actually
be leaving patients in worse conditions
and this was the century where
scientists began to consider an
alternate explanation for disease one
built not on balances of humors but
rather on the existence of germs and
that opened up new approaches to
treatment one that did not rely on
latching a blood-sucking worm onto
people's skin so the leech trade
eventually died out but the combination
of our use of leeches and the decline of
their Wetland habitat as left its mark
on the haruto medicinals population at
first it seemed like they might have
gone extinct entirely in Western Europe
but reports of their demise seemed to
have been exact rated not that reality
is that much better if you look up their
status in various countries in Western
Europe you'll see every label from not
threatened to rare to extinct to unknown
but they actually have made a comeback
in medicine not to the same degree that
they were used before but haruto
medicinals and their close relative
haruto verbena are used in hospitals for
certain treatments like draining the
clotted blood of hematomas and aside
from their medical uses leeches have a
well-studied system of ganglia the
cluster of neurons that you can see here
and that has made leeches a useful model
for scientists to use to better
understand the interplay between an
animal's nervous system and Its Behavior
so our history continues to be entwined
with the leech and while we started by
asking whether we are really the leech
here maybe that's too simple a question
this is an animal whose life is
intrinsically connected to hours through
blood a relationship forged through
Evolution and reshaped by history so
maybe the question isn't one we can
answer but rather something open-ended
if a leech has been a worm a parasite a
doctor an action what else can it be
yet no
thank you for coming on this journey
with us as we explore the Unseen World
that surrounds us the people whose names
are on the screen right now they are our
patreon patrons the people who make it
possible for us to make this content and
while some of them may be questioning
their decision considering how much a
leech content just got thrown at them I
think that most of them are very
satisfied with the decision we certainly
keep our patrons for a long time and we
very much appreciate that if you would
like to become one of our patreon
patrons you can join us at patreon.com
journey to micro if you want to see more
from our master of microscopes James
Weiss because he's always doing
wonderful and amazing things you can
check out jam and germs on Instagram and
if you want to see more from us there's
always a subscribe button somewhere
nearby